et y comment ça va regardez os corner
aujourd'hui on est à l'autodrome de
linas-montlhéry en rien notre vitesse on
va pas aller faire de la vitesse ici on
vient présenter surtout le nissan
qashqai power mais on pouvait pas passer
à côté du arias le crossover arias 100%
électrique avec un design qui est
absolument incroyable un tableau de bord
totalement épuré vraiment magnifique
alors le ariane où on va pas en parler
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va vraiment se
centrer sur les technologies du qashqai
le nouveau qashqai troisième génération
qui est hyper canon on est ici sur un
système que vous n'avez probablement
jamais vu c'est une innovation c'est
tout nouveau sa main d'arriver en france
le epower vous avez de l'électrique vous
avez un débris d'une nouvelle façon de
concevoir les brit mais ça on en parle
un peu plus dans la vidéo dont vous
restez vous regardez bien évidemment ils
vont garder jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qashqai epower ils sont énervés chez
nissan ils ont fait un truc vraiment
différent alors on reprend un peu
l'histoire vous connaissez les voitures
thermiques sur un peu l'ancienne
histoire ça serait écrit on va vers
l'électrique de l'autre côté et au
milieu vous avez l'hybride alors les
brit vous connaissait ça fait quoi eh
bien ça mélange un peu les deux mondes
ça veut dire que sur une hybride
classique lorsque vous allez conduire
vous roulez à petite vitesse vous êtes
en électrique vous appuie un peu plus le
moteur thermique prend le relais c'est
parti d'un tas donc ça c'est un peu
l'histoire de l'hybride sauf que chez
nissan ils sont bien faire les choses un
petit peu différemment et aux sorties le
nissan qashqai epower alors le epower ça
existait déjà avant mais du côté du
japon ça arrive ici en france comment
est-ce qu'on voit un peu l'histoire
c'est un peu comme un alternat temps je
vous explique l'histoire vous avez donc
votre hybride vous aller au bout et tout
le temps électrique tout en petites
vitesses grande vitesse salle électrique
en permanence vous avez votre moteur
électrique qui envoie directement la
patate au niveau des roues donc quoi
qu'il se passe elle électrique intérêts
l'électrique ça va être le silence ça va
être le couple c'est cool et derrière
pour nir alimenter cette batterie
électrique on utilise quoi le thermique
ça veut donc dire qu'en fait vous avez
un moteur thermique qui vient alimenter
l'électrique donc on utilise l'hybride
mais d'une autre manière donc le truc
est assez marrant ce internés cours à
avoir déjà du silence d'être peinard
d'avoir le coup d'avoir la reprise donc
ça c'est bien mais d'abord derrière du
thermique qui va consommer moins nous
annonce un petit 5 l'ic3 au sens plutôt
intéressante ce que je vous propose
c'est un bon dans la voiture on sent un
petit tour on est ici sur un circuit où
on est peinards on est à la maison il ya
personne pour me dire tu peux pas rouler
vite tu roule pas comme il faut on fait
ce qu'on veut on est chez nous on est
sur un modèle de présérie pour qu'on va
se balader venez avec moi on va à bord
du nouveau qashqai epower
[Musique]
donc là je en train de conduire on est
totalement ici en électrique c'est à
dire que lorsque j'appuie à celle
électrique mais on entend le moteur
pourquoi c'est comme je vous le disais
derrière vous avez deux moteurs qui va
venir lui alimenter les batteries qui va
alimenter l'électrique alors il ya
différentes solutions c'est à dire
qu'effectivement lorsque je suis là à
regarder je lâche le pied up et bien ça
continue à avancer mais il ya également
la conduite ip dalle qui vous permettra
d'avoir de la récupération d'énergie et
ya également un autre mode s'appelle le
mode b le mode brake qui va servir
également pour la récupération d'énergie
donc en fait on va pouvoir accélérer
rouler au pouvoir récupérer gardé de
l'autonomie on va avoir effectivement
cette autonomie qui va arriver deux par
le moteur thermique mais également grâce
à votre conduite avec la récupération
d'énergie par des montants c'est assez
simple donc là je viens activé mon ip
dalle donc voyez lâche en train de
conduire normalement et lorsque je lève
le pied de la [ __ ] d'accélérateur ça
va venir freiner on le sent que ça
freine on est un peu sur le devant et en
fait c'est la récupération d'énergie est
stocké vachement intéressant alors plus
vous allez être dans une pente plus vous
allez levez le pied plus ça va freiner
plus vous allez récupérer d'énergie donc
on vient récupérer un petit peu en
autonomie ici directement donc ça c'est
cool il ya une autre mode qui est
intéressant lâché en mode des modes de
conduite un peu standard c'est le mode b
b break et ouais on parle anglais ici là
haut puis passez en mode b donc lâché en
mode b c'est bien écrit le mode bay via
un complément de l'aïs pédales c'est à
dire qu'il vient régénérer davantage
d'énergie donc lorsque je lève le pied
ça va freiner davantage alors l'idée
c'est pas d'appuyer levé pied sinon ça
n'a aucun sens vous arrêter comme ça ça
sert strictement rien l'idée c'est que
vous allez avoir une seule [ __ ] pour
venir conduire pour venir piloter votre
[ __ ] d'accélération qui vous servira à
venir dosé à la fois vos gars que vous
allez accéléré bien évidemment on va pas
dire jeter contre les murs et pas le but
ici est en même temps lorsque vous levez
le pied ça vient légèrement freiné donc
ça c'est intéressant alors on est sur un
circuit donc vous dit forcément monte à
tripoli intérêts mais lorsque vous
conduisez en ville ce un vrai intérêt
c'est super pratique parce que comme ça
vous venez gérer totalement avec votre
[ __ ] d'accélération votre freinage
soit accélération et la [ __ ] de frein
vous utilisez vraiment parce qu'il faut
vraiment y aller quand en cas d'urgence
on appuie en fred mais sinon ce système
là est génial parce que avec une seule
[ __ ] on pilote tout et on récupère
l'énergie et on gagne de l'autonomie ça
c'est cool et là vous avez levé mode
voyez ces cris en dessous avait mode
levé mode vous nul est totalement le
moteur thermique siècle à vous voulez
uniquement sur la batterie en électrique
vos batteries ne sont plus alimentés par
le moteur thermique donc on est 100 %
électrique l'idée c'est lorsque vous
roulez à faible vitesse tranquillement
en ville eh bien vous êtes que sur
l'électrique pourquoi pas c'est plutôt
marrant alors après si vous appuyez
franck rugby et que vous partez dans un
plat en parement pokola le moteur
thermique repas révolue marque mode
veille indisponible je relève un peu le
pied j'aurais pu surveiller motards
roulent un peu trop vite lâché à 32 par
défaut je freine un petit peu et
l'intérêt de lever mode c'est
effectivement vous dire vous êtes envie
de vous voulez pas très vite baltard
c'est que l'électrique donc c'est plutôt
cool alors après on va pas hyper hyper
long avec sa attention on nous annonce 5
km on sait qu'on peut aller un peu plus
loin et à une vitesse relativement
faible mais c'est une petite option qui
est assez intéressante parce qu'on est
une fois de plus dans l'hybride mais
dans l'idée de l'électrique
électrification ça c'est bien et après
vous avez le des modes et avec le demos
vous avez trois modes de conduite sport
standards & co ça va dépendre de votre
façon de conduire alors bien évidemment
le mode sport ne recommande pas on va
venir consommer on va aller plus loin si
un jour vous voulez un petit peu
pourquoi pas du tout façon on peut pas
rouler alors là sur ce circuit on peut y
aller en mode sport sur veut mais vous
je vous conseille l'écho comme ça on est
toujours dans la même idée économique
conduite économies d'énergie
récupération et si vous aligner toutes
les planètes avec le lit [ __ ] le mode
break l'économie et ben vous allez loin
savez qui veut aller loin ménage sa
monture donc nous on ménage de peinture
on est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est marrant cette idée et capri nissan
ici parce que nissan si on connaît
nissan c'est l'inventeur du crossover le
crossover cdvm nissan il l'a fait et la
vienne encore réinventer l'histoire il
est encore révolutionner l'automobile en
ce moment est vraiment totalement en
train de se changer en train de se ré
écrire en train de révolutionner il ya
des besoins attention c'est sûr c'est
nécessaire il ya des besoins climatique
et d entre eux sont très très forts mais
là c'est une façon un peu différente de
prendre les choses on connaît le
thermique on connaît l électrique on
connait l'hybride maintenant il ya
l'hybride epower c'est nouveau ça arrive
en france tout ça extrêmement malin et
c'est chouette de voir un constructeur
innover innove tous en ce moment ils
font tous un petit peu énervant
attendait qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer ces
différences et différenciant ces six des
dix années et ça c'est hyper chouette
[Musique]
et chez nissan on a le propre lot alors
le propre lot ça va se caler par rapport
à votre régulateur de vitesse à des jeux
peu augmenté de ma vitesse dont vous
connaissez les régulateurs de vitesse
c'est pas tout nouveau mais l'intérêt du
propos y los que vous avez également dû
lane assist va vous regarder sur votre
voix alors il faut des lignes en fait
sur autoroute guen évidemment et en
garde la main sur le volant ça c'est la
réglementation qui vous lobby est comme
ça vous avez vraiment totalement et
régulateur de vitesse qui est totalement
adaptatif c'est pratique c'est sympa les
petites techniques sont très chouette
qui vont vous aider également notamment
sur les trajets longs on pense aux
autoroutes 1 lorsque vous partez en
vacances avec la famille ben ça évite
quand même pas mal de fatigue et ça m'a
vraiment tenir vous aider notamment
c'est une voiture devant qui se met à
freiner et bien la voiture elle va
s'adapter et ça peut sauver la vie et ça
c'est chouette l'affichage central je
trouve vachement pratique gardez vous
venez naviguer sur la gauche vous avez
défilé vous avez votre maison vous avez
toutes les informations de conduite la
pression des pneus est votre voiture
votre gps zeina une petite boussole pour
savoir dans quel sens vous êtes l'audio
of lepreau pilote est ici vos différents
paramètres et à chaque fois vous avez
des sous menus des menus des sous menus
dont je trouve que l'idée quand même
vachement cour a déboulé main
directement votre véhicule est alors il
ya note qui me plaît bien alors à droite
et à gauche va pas mon vitesse je vais
avoir mon compteur ma récupération
d'énergie le nombre de kilomètres que
j'ai fait plus toutes les options y
pédales ou pas qui sont activés mais je
peux venir modifier également joué dans
l'affichage personnel je connais un
modifier mon affichage si je le souhaite
regarder sur la partie de gauche par
exemple trajet temps reste en position
vitesse moyenne venir complètement
customisée l'expérience ça c'est très
très chouette j'ai également tous les
paramètres d'affichage avec la sélection
du contenu je peux venir édité l'écran
de bienvenue et je la voir tous les
paramètres de mon véhicule réglage du
véhicule par exemple le hayon électrique
fin bref sauf que c'est assez simple
c'est risible c'est clair on comprend
tout et tout ça vraiment pas mal et au
centre vous avez un écran qui est
suffisamment grand avec toutes les
informations alors sur l'accueil vous
avez pas mal d'infos gps la météo amazon
avec ça qu'on peut venir connecter
également et puis vous avez plein de
widgets comptes utilisateurs pouvaient
mettre là j'ai collecté ou d'iphone je
vais vous expliquer la météo nissan
connect série 6 et là je peux venir
ajouté plein de petits widgets lors de
l'horloge de la connexion de l'amazone
alexa tous les côtés un peu de tomtom
également envoyé donc le taux qui est
quand même plutôt pas mal fichu donc ça
c'est pour l'accueil je vais avoir en
dessous ma navigation complète en plein
écran avec de la recherche google plutôt
pas mal en dessous la musique alors moi
j'ai branché apple car plaît parce qu'il
s'agit apple car play filaire mais
également bluetooth mais on a aussi
android auto uniquement aux filières ici
au dessus je pouvais avoir la rade oh et
toutes mes sources audio j'ai deux
entrées usb le bluetooth apple car play
et puis des applications ici si je le
souhaite et on sue je vais avoir mes
différents réglages et mes différentes
applications les notifications nissan
connect service où suis-je sur les
perdus c'est plutôt pratique la position
gps la météo et puis après différentes
zac on peut me retrouver ici tout en
sachant qu'en plus vous avez un petit
bouton ici bouton caméra vous appuyez et
paf vous retrouvé vos caméras la
position d'autres véhicules et la caméra
arrière et l'avait pouvoir changer la
luminosité mode jour mode nuit avancer
reculer les morceaux le volume on appuie
c'est très épuré ces pratiques mais ça
marche bien
[Musique]
j'utilise ici on va retrouver tout ce
qui va être climatisation chauffage
volant chauffant et compagnie pour
l'intérieur du véhicule on va retrouver
ici le start stop pour venir démarrer
votre véhicule plus petit prise 12 volts
pour recharger tout ce que vous voulez
et puis a pas de rechargement sans fil
elle aura un truc qui est vachement bien
c'est que moi j'ai un très grand
smartphone un iphone 13 promax et il
passe et ça c'est la très bonne nouvelle
vous avez un petit voyant qui vous
indique que vous êtes en train de
recharger et en dessous votre ses
lecteurs pour venir choisir votre mode
drive break reculer ou neutres votre
mode de conduite eco ou compagnes et ip
d'alves et mode bref tout ce passe ici
et puis deux porte-gobelets parce que ça
reste quand même vachement pratique et
sous l'accoudoir vous avez deux prises
usb c'est une usb pour brancher votre
smartphone apple car pelé ou android
auto comme vous le voyez également et à
l'arrière du véhicule vous avez une
prise usb cd usb à pour venir charger
vos smartphones avoir une belle voiture
connectée c'est bien mais cette voiture
ce qu'on veut également ses profits
telle expérience on veut profiter de la
musique est déjà là voyez comme ça elle
chante un peu la voiture je passe aux
alentours elle chante en fait de même
c'est marrant vous êtes de systèmes de
recharge j'ai l'impression c'est une
petite musique écoutez ça et d'un
addendum sa superbe au bon ça c'est pour
rigoler on a un système bose à
l'intérieur on a de la musique ça envoie
du pâté venez écouter on va se mettre
dedans alors je voulais profiter
rapidement de la musique parce que ici
on est à montlhéry ils vont refaire
l'anneau de vitesse donc on peut pas
trop trop resté là pendant des heures
mais on va quand même s'envoyer un petit
peu de fond parce qu'on n'est pas là
pour se marrer enceintes bose ici là on
est également là on a les aigus si honda
les graves en bas et là on va y aller
écoutez moi ça va on est sur un niveau
un peu à la cool genre tu te balades à
la maison tout va bien si maintenant tu
invites ses copains les copines tu vas
faire un mode club
[Musique]
alors on y va un peu fort ça crache mais
comme ça là on a vraiment des graves qui
sont très rond les aigus sont là sont
plutôt pas mal tous que pour un système
embarqué audio jack temps dans votre
voiture vous pouvez y aller franchement
[Musique]
ici vous avez quatre finitions vous
n'avez pas trop argent n'est pas 2 vous
avez quatre finissants taille a4
finition plus une salle là c'est la
business donc on la veut pas on la sort
demain vous soyez d'entreprise et que
vous voulez acheter un qashqai
directement business non quatre
finitions quatre couleurs différentes
par contre ici nissan ne sont pas là
pour rigoler ils ont mis tout ce qui est
sécurité directement dès l'entrée de
gamme dans ce véhicule donc ça c'est
quand même plutôt bien c'est rassurant
dans quel que soit le véhicule que vous
allez prendre vous avez tout ce qu'il
faut en terme de sécurité et ça c'est
bien bravo nissan
[Musique]
je veux qu'on parle un peu
insonorisation de véhicules parce que ça
en point qui est vraiment venu soulevé
nissan ont des ans un véhicule qui est
plutôt de bon au niveau du son alors
c'est vrai que moi j'en viens d'un essai
au tout de suite où il y avait soit %
électrique donc je n'entendais rien et
là je trouve que j'entends un peu donc
j'ai un peu ce petit billet mais c'est
vrai que par rapport à une thermique
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
silencieux mais par rapport au nom
électrique fatalement comme on est un
moteur thermique derrière on s'en
doutera ça fait un peu plus de bruit en
fait ce qu'il faut bien comprendre avec
cette hybride la sai que on vient se
situer à mi-chemin entre un électrique
et thermique et c'est la même chose au
niveau de la sonorisation c'est à dire
qu'en fait vous allez pas avoir le bruit
d'un moteur thermique mais pour autant
vous avez un moteur thermique alors il
est évident que si vous appuyez re année
on va appuyer un peu plus là on est à 50
voiliers l'aja puis là on l'entend
vraiment parce que ça nécessite
fatalement d'avoir un peu plus de
motorisation derrière donc sort un peu
plus de bois mais lorsqu'on roule
cadence un petit peu modéré aux
alentours des 50 60 kilomètres/heure est
bien le moteur se fait un peu plus
oublié par rapport à un moteur thermique
mais on entendra davantage bien
évidemment par rapport à un moteur
électrique parce qu'il n'y a pas de
moteur c'est logique c'est comme ça
alors après on pures sensations de
conduite moi je trouve que ce véhicule
il est plutôt sympa à conduire il assez
souple et répondent bien en termes de
tenue de route c'est bon alors ce sera
pas aussi bon qu'en 100 % électrique ou
le centre de gravité est un peu plus bas
là c'est un peu différent on va pas non
plus allé se jeter par tous un véhicule
car un peu plus on est sur un crossover
fatalement donc c'est pas la même tenue
de route mais pour autant sur une
conduite normale norme et où on vient se
balader ça fonctionne bien c'est
pratique c'est sympa peut vous balader
très facilement dans les virages ça me
semble correct j'ai pas roulé pendant
des heures et des heures et des heures
mais la sueur des premiers essais à
chaud je puis vous assurer que je prends
un plaisir de conduire et ça ça fait du
bien 1 mon coco ouais territoire
passagers ouais tu te sens bien j'ai
coupé laquelle ça fait du bruit je vais
crever de chaud alors regarder un petit
peu au niveau de la réactivité quand on
appuie sa marche un peu alors on est sur
un circuit routier c'est pas un circuit
de vitesse donc on va se calmer on a
beau être à montlhéry on va pas jeter
dans les murs c'est pas le but là on
prend le centre et aux vaccins en sortie
de virage là le circuit il un peu dans
son jeu donc ça secoue un peu donc je
sais qu'on va avoir peur donc
pour un suv hybride comme ça en
crossover on arrive à faire des choses
quand même mais bon là j'ai mon coco
arrière qui ont peu plus donc bon je
vais devoir lever le pied quoi
[Musique]
et non à l'affichage tête haute alors
ici on va avoir effectivement la vitesse
à laquelle je roule c'est pas très vite
voiliers et puis si on a un gps va avoir
les données de navigation ce qui n'est
pas le cas ici chez mamie gps on les
sent circuit on n'est pas perdue donc ça
c'est quand même très très pratique
lorsque vous conduisez voyez comme ça
d'avoir cette information devant vous je
me vois très bien alors ça prendra
peut-être pas forcément bien la caméra
c'est pas toujours évident mais
personnellement je le vois quand même
vachement bien c'est extrêmement
pratique et ça une fois de plus en
termes de qualité de conduite de confort
c'est vachement bien
[Musique]
bon alors j'aime bien crier dans les
bois alors qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce que ça raconte cette nouvelle qashqai
nissan qashqai epower ils pourront voir
ces écrits ici voilà comme ça je vous
fais la corée il sant qashqai epower ben
ça raconte que c'est un tout qui est
différent c'est une nouvelle façon de
venir concevoir l'hybride ils font un
peu les choses un peu différemment ça
peut à leur sauce j'ai dit saad ça
raconte une autre histoire et je trouve
ça intéressant pour qui pourquoi pas
pour tout le monde pour ceux qui veulent
aller aux 100 % électrique qui ont une
maison qui peuvent se recharger ou qui
peuvent changer l'entreprise vous n'irez
pas là dessus ça c'est la voiture qui
est fait pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas se
recharger qui veulent aller dans
l'hybride mais qui ne veulent pas tout
de suite ou qui ne peuvent pas passer à
l'électrique c'est un peul entre deux
centrales thermiques entre l'électrique
il est évident que ces petits pots logis
de voitures hybrides à terme ça finira
par disparaître mais dans longtemps dans
très longtemps donc vous avez le temps
vous pouvez y aller ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est effectivement la
technologie power qui est totalement
différente par rapport à sokodé
l'hybride donc si vous aimez l'hybride
un peu conventionnel avec un relais
électrique thermique s'était pas celle
là si maintenant vous voulez de
l'hybride différente avec du thermique
tout en arrière qui va vous permettre et
bien de profiter d'une sensation 100%
électrique mais avec un thermique sans
besoin de recharger eh bien je pense que
ces voitures peut être fait pour vous
cette nissan qashqai power elle est
différente elle est très différente elle
est la seule sur le marché français
comme ça aujourd'hui donc si vous voulez
tenter une nouvelle aventure dans
l'hybride si vous aimez le design de
cette nouvelle qashqai epower si vous
aimez le travail du constructeur
japonais nissan et que vous voulez vivre
une nouvelle aventure hybride et bien il
se peut qu'elle soit faite pour vous moi
je trouve intéressant et plutôt sympa
jolie proposition à vous de me dire vous
ce que vous en pensez oui vous vous toi
derrière qu'est ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est ce qu'elles
pourraient vous tentez ce qu'elle vous
intéresse qu est ce que vous pensez de
toute la connectivité puis surtout
qu'est ce que vous pensez à technologie
power qui pour le coup est quand même
relativement différente différentes
attention c'est intéressant parce que
compliquer pour alimenter électriquement
du thermique ce qu'il veut un peu le
truc mais pour autant c'est l'hybride ça
reste de l'hybride avec une faible
consommation c'est juste que c'est un
autre cheminement mais c'est intéressant
il pas tout ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaires dont on se retrouve vite
pour continuer à parler terry continue à
parler d'automobiles et puis voilà 1
c'est bien non
j'ai fait un vrai temps de chacun des
pilotes tu veux tu auras tu te rappelles
toi et hic on peut se faire un tour de
circuit un peu hardcore un truc où coco
avoir peur c'est pas une voiture de
sport
on va mettre du rythme ok on met du
rythme avec eric le new school et on a
mangé attention des fragiles de
l'estomac elle est partie
oh oh oh oh oh
oh
[Musique]
non